guten tag guten tag entschuldigung darf
ich sie etwas fragen
entschuldigung darf ich sie etwas fragen
kreiert sie natürlich
natürlich
[Musik]
wie kann ich ihnen behilflich sein
entschuldigen sie ich verstehe kein
schweizerdeutsch
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
gibt es diesen kleiderschrank auch in
schwarz
[Musik]
ja wir haben ihn in schwarz braun beige
und weiß
ist schwarz gefällt mir gut
es schwarz gefällt mir gut
zu diesem modell haben wir auch ein
passendes regal einen nachtisch und eine
kommode
zu diesem modell haben wir auch ein
passendes regal einen nachttisch und
eine kommode
[Musik]
möchten sie sie sehen
wie bitte
wir haben auch ein regal einen
nachttisch und eine kommode in dieser
farbe
wir haben auch ein regal einen
nachttisch und eine kommode in dieser
farbe
das passt gut zusammen
[Musik]
nein danke ich brauche nur einen
kleiderschrank
wie hoch und wie breit ist er
210 cm hoch und 80 cm breit
das passt perfekt
wie viel kostet der schrank
er kostet 560 franken
gut ich kaufe
schrank
gut ich kaufe den schrank
wenn sie möchten liefern wir ihn
liefern entschuldigung was bedeutet das
liefern heißt zu ihnen nach hause
bringen
ich verstehe
wie viel kostet das
die lieferung kostet 60 franken
alles zusammen kostet 620 franken
ja das ist gut
wann können sie mir den kleiderschrank
bringen
wenn sie möchten schon am mittwochmorgen
um 9 uhr
das geht leider nicht dann bin ich nicht
zu hause
wir hätten am donnerstagnachmittag noch
zeit geht das
ja wann
um
15 uhr
in ordnung
ich brauche noch in den namen ihre
adresse und ihre telefonnummer
immer nowak tannenweg 23 23 5 erlach
und die telefonnummer ist 0 78 938 28 49
m
tannenweg 23 23 5 erlach
und die telefonnummer ist 0 78 938 28 49
gut danke
[Musik]
kann ich mit der karte bezahlen
natürlich
so vielen dank
auf wiedersehen frau nowak
auf wiedersehen danke auf wiedersehen
danke
verpasse kein neues video von der hallo
deutsche schule
abonniere unseren kanal
verpasse kein neues video von der hallo
deutsche schule
[Musik]
abonniere unseren kanal